verschwörungstheorien verbreiten sich
jetzt in der korona krise immer mehr
und obwohl forschungsteams weltweit
täglich immer neue erkenntnisse zu dem
neuartigen virus bekommen verbreiten
sich diese falsche informationen zu dem
rasen schnell teilweise sind sie sogar
echte medizinerinnen und mediziner die
den gängigen einschätzung von politik
und wissenschaft widersprechen hier
einige der grössten verschwörungs mythen
zu corona und außerdem auch die
erklärung dazu warum diese nicht stimmen
können klicks umsatz im pfizer die gibt
es dreimal pro woche spannendes hand sie
das abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke denn nur so verpasste er
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
klick substanzen future gibt es jetzt
auch nur für die ohren in der u-bahn
oder im auto oder auch so auf dem sofa
der link ist hier unter me und in der
video beschreibung
es ist ein super schmaler grat auf dem
seriöse journalistinnen und journalisten
derzeit passieren denn seit beginn der
korona pandemie ist es eine riesige
menge an unsinn die im netz die runde
macht und schon stehen leute wie ich vor
dem folgenden dilemma sollen wir den
ganzen irrsinn einfach ignorieren oder
aber über die falsche informationen
berichten und damit deren verfassern
eine plattform bieten ignorieren kommt
für mich nicht in frage denn dafür ist
die gefahr einfach zu groß denn das
könnte im schlimmsten fall menschenleben
kosten und unsere demokratie schwächen
dazu später mehr und so sehe ich es als
meine aufgabe an gegen
verschwörungstheorien anzugehen denn die
sind längst in der mitte unserer
gesellschaft angekommen das zeigt auch
die zuletzt herausgegebene mitte studie
der friedrich ebert stiftung ear hatten
50 prozent der deutschen angegeben dass
sie lieber ihren gefühlen glauben als
expertinnen und experten es handelt sich
wirklich um eine besorgniserregende
zahlen die eine sache ganz deutlich
macht viele menschen sind verunsichert
und haben angst davor die kontrolle zu
verlieren sie suchen nach strategien um
damit umzugehen und genau das lässt
verschwörungstheorien groß werden denn
dadurch wird die welt vermeintlich
wieder ein wenig strukturierter wie und
warum verschwörungstheorien überhaupt
geglaubt oder verbreitet werden darüber
habe ich ja auch ein video gemacht der
link dazu ist hier unter mir und in der
video beschreiben
verschwörungstheorien geben dingen oder
ereignissen also plötzlich wieder einen
sinn zumindest in den augen ihrer
anhängerinnen und anhänger ein fataler
irrtum und manchen politikerinnen und
politikern zufolge befinden wir uns
derzeit sogar in einem zitat weltweiten
informations kampf zu corona es ist
tatsächlich allerhöchste zeit zu handeln
denn wir haben verschwörungstheorien in
ihrer gefährlichkeit viel zu lange
unterschätzt nur ein beispiel dafür
auch die attentäter von hanna und alle
glaubten an verschwörungstheorien zudem
zeigen zahlreiche studien dass menschen
mit verschwörungs glauben gewalt als
option für politisches handeln ansehen
und dass sie sich eher politischen
alternativen außerhalb des
demokratischen spektrums zu wenden
besonders schwierig wird es vor allem
dann wenn vermeintliche autoritäten
falschinformationen verbreiten sowie
derzeit einige mediziner die sich ja
vermeintlich gut in diesem fachbereich
auskennen sollten es gibt in jedem
bereich schwarze schafe und so sind auch
ärztinnen und ärzte bei den sogenannten
hygiene demos dabei und werden nicht
müde immer wieder auf ihre fachexperte
zu verweisen wichtig hier
man muss zwischen ärzten und ärztinnen
auf der einen seite und forschenden auf
der anderen seite unterscheiden nur die
forschenden haben wirklich einen
aktuellen überblick über die forschung
und das auch nur wenn sie in diesem
forschungsbereich aktiv sind ärzte und
ärztinnen haben ihre ausbildung meist
vor einigen jahren gemacht und wänden
lediglich gut erprobtes fachwissen an
viele der teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
dieser jene die muss halten das corona
virus für einen internationalen putsch
mit dem eine systemkrise überdeckt
werden soll
der geheime plan sei es demnach eine art
weltherrschaft zu installieren das ja
kann man so eigentlich nicht stehen
lassen meinen beitrag zu dem ganzen ein
video mit den drei größten verschwörungs
mythen zum corona wir uns gleich mit
dazu gibt es auch die erklärung warum
sie einfach nicht stimmen können fangen
wir an mit dem lungenfacharzt wolfgang
wodarg kurz zur person selbst wolfgang
wodarg hat ein medizinstudium absolviert
und war sogar einmal leiter des
gesundheitsamtes in flensburg zudem war
er stipendiat der johns hopkins
universität in den usa kennt man von den
corona karten in seinem lebenslauf zu
finden auch ein abstecher in die politik
wurde saß insgesamt 15 jahre lang für
die spd im deutschen bundestag von 1994
bis 2009 und das bedeutet wolfgang
wodarg
expertise aufweisen und das ist für
viele anlass ihn ernst zu nehmen wo dann
ist der ansicht dass das corona virus
nicht unbedingt gefährlicher ist als die
grippe und somit die angst der menschen
und bestimmte maßnahmen unbegründet sein
er behauptet dass es coronaviren beim
menschen schon seit langer zeit gibt und
dass diese seit jeher zu den vielen
todesfällen in der grippesaison
beitragen die ganze aufmerksamkeit die
das corona wir uns jetzt bekommt liegt
wodak zufolge daran dass jetzt auf das
virus getestet werden kann der
unterstellen anderen forscherinnen und
forschern wobei er ist ja gar kein
forscher dass sie mit den crooner test
nur die große kohle und sich selbst
wichtig machen wollen viele youtube
userinnen und user feiern montag wie
einen helden so kommentiert
beispielsweise magic neo 78 unter einer
der videos in den montag spricht sehr
geehrter herr dr wolfram morath sie sind
ein sehr sympathischer und kompetenter
arzt sie haben von anfang an recht was
die kobik 19 pandemie angeht sie sind
für mich die große hoffnung in dieser
schwierigen zeit ich bedanke mich
vielmals für ihren mut und ihren
engagement
ich wünsche ihnen viel kraft für die
zukunft jetzt wird es an der zeit dass
wir alle aufwachen viele grüße
schaut man sich wo das videos an wird
schnell klar dass er in seiner
argumentation äußerst geschickt vorgeht
seine aussagen sind auch keineswegs alle
falsch und so vertrauen ihm mittlerweile
auch menschen die selbst medizinischen
background haben doch schaut man mal
genauer hin welche youtube-kanäle seine
inhalte verbreiten da kann man stutzig
werden auf manchen kanälen geht es
hauptsächlich um chemtrails und satan
aber auch rechtsextreme themen sind hier
ganz vorne mit dabei zahlreiche
fachleute halten wo dax aussagen für
sehr gefährlich vor allem seine
schlussfolgerungen sind schwierig so
sieht das auch der epidemiologe gérard
krause vom helmholtz zentrum für
infektionsforschung er sagt in einem
interview mit der ard sendung monitor
der großteil seiner aussagen ist
inhaltlich unstrittig ganz problematisch
ist seine schlussfolgerung dass es sich
hier nicht um ein problem handelt
sondern dass es nur ein
wahrnehmungsproblem ist und das ist
definitiv nicht der fall
die verstorbenen patienten und auch die
todesfälle beim medizinischen personal
sind ja nicht erfunden die wehren uns
auch aufgefallen wenn wir keine
erfassungssystem oder
einen namen für das virus hätten doch
auch innerhalb nicht entsprechend wo dax
thesen nicht alle dem aktuellen
wissensstand der seriösen wissenschaft
zum einen behauptet er ja dass das
neuartige virus nicht unbedingt
gefährlicher als die grippe seien zudem
tut er so als seien alle corona wären
gleich gefährlich und suggeriert dass
das neuartige virus sich aus einem
bekannten erreger entwickelt habe somit
verharmlost er ganz eindeutig die gefahr
der pandemie die fakten sehen aber so
aus im menschen kommen insgesamt sieben
coronaviren vor vier davon können
erkältung verursachen und gehen in der
bevölkerung herum
ein großteil der menschen ist immun und
so breiten sich diese viren langsam aus
also langsam aus bei saas märz und dem
neuartigen kroner viruslast oft 2 kommt
es häufiger zu schweren
atemwegserkrankungen und mehr
es gibt keine immunität und weil der
menschliche körper diese viren nicht
kennt der biologe christian drosten sagt
dazu in seinem ende podcast dazu kommt
dann noch dass der verlauf mit diesem
neuen corona wäre es nicht so harmlos
ist wie mit diesen als bekannten
alteingesessenen corona werden
heißt also im klartext wodak spielt in
seiner argumentation zwei gefahren von
saas kopf zwei herunter und das ist
gefährlich zum einen die hohe
infektiösität und zum anderen nutzt er
die tatsache dass viele betroffene nur
schwach oder gar keine symptome zeigen
was aber für die wenigen die schlimme
symptome haben und schwer erkranken auch
kein trost ist außerdem ist auch der
vergleich mit der grippe nicht
angebracht denn gegen das neuartige
coronaviren gibt es bisher noch keine
wirklich erprobten medikamente oder
impfungen und zuletzt noch zu seiner
aussage dass es sich bei saas kopf zwei
gar nicht um einen neuen erreger typ
handele sondern das einer der bekannten
coronaviren mutiert sei seiner meinung
nach etwas völlig normales tatsächlich
stimmt es dass viren oft notieren
deswegen brauchen wir ja auch jedes jahr
einen neuen impfstoff für die krippe
doch fachleute weltweit sind sich sicher
dass saas kopf zwei ende des vergangenen
jahres 2009 10 erstmals von einem tier
auf den menschen übergesprungen ist und
bitteschön warum soll ein mutiertes
virus der nicht tödlich sein wenn die
gentechnik kritisiert wird ist das ja
immer das argument und zudem hat mit 19
ja gezeigt dass es tödlicher als
bisheriger grippeepidemien ist auch der
studierte mediziner andy kaufman
verbreitet zum corona virus
falschinformationen im
er bezeichnet unter anderem die
maßnahmen als panikmache übersetzt ich
finde die meisten maßnahmen die von den
gesundheitsbehörden und regierung
angeordnet worden sind haben die angst
noch verstärkt das von den menschen
erwartet wird in der öffentlichkeit
masken zu tragen und angst vor zwischen
menschlicher nähe zu haben erhöht
natürlich das maß an angst und besorgnis
und das alles scheint der bestandteil
dieser kampagne zu sein
er geht davon aus dass es gar keine
pandemie gibt die positiven tests würden
nicht auf dem nachweis von saas koch 2
beruhen sondern auf der existenz
sogenannter explosionen oder anders
ausgedrückt kaufmann glaubt dass die
eingesetzten tests gar keine coronaviren
identifizieren er bezieht sich auf eine
ziemlich alte studie aus dem jahr 1987
in der eine forschungsgruppe den begriff
der exklusive geprägt hat dabei handelt
es sich um membranbläschen die von
vielen zelltypen gebildet werden wenn
zellulärer stress vorhanden ist laut
kaufmann sind die biologischen
eigenschaften von lars koch 2 und
explosionen identisch aber selbst das
stimmt nicht
also die tests liefern seiner ansicht
nach zur folge positive ergebnisse weil
sich in ihrem gewebe explosion befinden
dazu hat eine sprecherin des robert koch
instituts auf unsere anfrage hin am 14
08 und 2020 per e-mail stellung genommen
sie schreibt inwiefern exzessen und saß
kopf zwei identisch sein sollten
erschließt sich mir nicht extra summen
kommen in jedem menschen vor das würde
also im umkehrschluss bedeuten jeder
test auf saas koch 2 müsste positiv sein
sollte beides gleichermaßen vom pcr test
nachgewiesen werden was definitiv nicht
zutrifft und nochmal extra sum und saß
koch 2 sind nicht identisch auch die
größe obwohl behauptet stimmt aber nicht
ist unterschiedlich seriöse fachleute
weltweit bezeichnen die detektion von
saas kopf zwei nukleinsäure mit hilfe
der real time pcr als goldstandard zum
nachweis einer akuten infektion mit dem
erreger die abkürzung ccs steht für
polymerase kettenreaktion und wird schon
seit langer zeit eingesetzt um
infektionskrankheiten so diagnostizieren
als falsch positive tests sind es
gemeint die ein positives ergebnis haben
und das obwohl die patientin oder der
patient sich gar nicht mit dem
neuartigen corona virus infiziert hat
gesehen von kaufman gibt es bei youtube
weitere videos in denen behauptet wird
dass pcr test zum nachweis von kroner
infektionen in bis zu 50 der fälle
falsche ergebnisse liefern
das behauptet beispielsweise auch der
internist claus köhnlein dessen video
knapp 900.000 mal aufgerufen wurde
genau deshalb werde das ausmaß der
pandemie überschätzt die wissenschaft
aber weiß dass das nicht stimmt das
robert-koch-institut kann eine angabe
von 30 bis 50 prozent falsch positiver
test nicht nachvollziehen
nach angaben des virologen christian
drosten hat es eine validierungsstudie
im rahmen der pcr test entwicklung
gegeben und zwar mit einer großen anzahl
echter patientenproben in denen sich
positive nachweise anderer coronaviren
und auch andere erkältungsviren befunden
hatten dazu drosten und nicht ein
einziges mal hat es da eine falsche
positive reaktion gegeben
also dieser tests reagiert gegen kein
anderes corona virus des menschen und
gegen kein anderes erkältungsvirus des
menschen zusammenfassend kann man also
sagen dass die pcr tests auf saas kopf
zwei sehr genau sind pauschale prothesen
die von einer fehlerquote von bis zu 50
prozent ausgehen entsprechen nicht dem
bisherigen wissensstand der seriösen
wissenschaft der recherchen verbund
korrektiv hat dazu beispielsweise drei
unikliniken in deutschland befragt
danach sind die test qualitativ
hochwertig und weisen eine geringe
fehlerquote auf zudem sagen
verschwörungstheoretiker und
verschwörungstheoretiker rinnen ja immer
man soll mal selbst im netz
recherchieren und ich kann nur sagen
dass ich das ganz oft und jedesmal stoße
ich nach ein paar klicks auf einen stopp
bei kaufman war es sein fachgebiet er
ist psychiater
soviel dazu auch der youtuber coach
cecil verbreitet über seinen kanal
falsche aussagen zur corona pandemie
normalerweise beschäftigt er sich mit
sport und nahrungsergänzungsmitteln
diese soll er auch mal als mittel gegen
korona beworben haben vorsicht vor
solchen wahnwitzigen versprechen der
titel eines seiner videos aus dem mai
lautet aufgeflogen die wahren mächte
volks verrat und er verspricht den
leuten das zitat heftigste video von
allen corona videos in denen es um die
zitat ganzen verstrickung von bill gates
und den ganz
organisationen geht doch anders als er
es verspricht zählt er nicht allein die
fakten auf sondern verbreitet wirklich
großen sind zum einen behauptet sessel
dass bill gates der hauptsponsor der
weltgesundheitsorganisation who sei eine
ähnliche these hatte ja auch bereits
kennen jetzt aufgestellt auch darüber
hatten wir hier bei pixum science and
future ausführlich berichtet fakt aber
ist auch wenn die bill & melinda gates
foundation in den vergangenen jahren
viel geld in die whu gesteckt hat macht
das nicht den hauptteil des budgets aus
doch cecil greift in seinem video nicht
nur bill gates und die whu an sondern
auch das deutsche robert koch-institut
er behauptet dass in den offiziellen
statistiken die genesenen patientinnen
und patienten nicht aufgezählt werden
als angeblichen beweis dafür zeigte ein
dashboard des rk ii 6 schaut man genau
hin werden die genesenen dort sehr wohl
gekennzeichnet und die zahlen zudem auch
jeden tag aktualisiert fakt ist
allerdings dass von der gesamtzahl der
bestätigten fälle nicht die zahl der
gelesenen abgezogen wird dazu schreibt
das team des robert koch instituts auf
seiner webseite daten darüber ob ein
patient wieder genesen ist werden nicht
offiziell erhoben die erhebung ist auch
nicht gesetzlich vorgesehen allerdings
kann man zumindest bei den fällen bei
denen die meisten angaben ermittelt
wurden und die keine schweren symptome
hatten die nicht in ein krankenhaus
eingewiesen wurden davon ausgehen dass
sie spätestens nach 14 tagen wieder
genesen sind das lka schätzt die zahl
der gelesenen und stellt sie täglich auf
dem rk ii dashboard und im
situationsbericht zur verfügung zudem
berichten immer wieder viele zeitungen
darüber wieviel aktuelle fälle es gibt
also das wird überhaupt nicht
verschwiegen 10 ziel aber suggeriert in
seinem video das das rk ii die zahl der
chinesen extra nicht abzieht umso angst
und panik zu schüren und das ist einfach
nicht korrekt das rk ii nennt die zahl
der gelesenen prominenten nicht nur im
dashboard sondern auch in seinen
lageberichten so war es beispielsweise
eben auch am 14.8 2020 der fall und noch
etwas corona scheint sich tatsächlich
abzuschwächen und das ist keine
verschwörungstheorie sondern an fakt den
übrigens auch alle mainstream medien
verbreiten also es gibt da überhaupt
keine verschwörung oder so etwas im
moment sind nur etwas über 219 erkrankte
auf der intensivstation in den deutschen
kliniken knapp 120 davon werden
hat mit die zahlen der schwer erkranken
sind also gerade im verhältnis zu den
steigenden infizierten zahlen sehr sehr
gering trotzdem wissen wir dass ohne
vorsichtsmaßnahmen wie masken und
abstand halten was ja auch wirklich
überhaupt keinen aufwand ist die zahlen
in den krankenhäusern exponentiell
wachsen werden diese erfahrung hat mir
schon im märz und april gemacht das gilt
aber ab egal welcher zahl und das
bedeutet immer am ende eine überlastung
und damit steigenden todeszahlen es ist
eben eine pandemie und es ist eine
tödliche pandemie und wir als betroffene
menschen müssen uns und unsere
mitmenschen davor schützen
das ist einfach ein gebot der
menschlichkeit und deswegen wird sicher
keine weltregierung die macht übernehmen
ein solches szenario ist schlichtweg
unmöglich aber die wirtschaft liefert
einbrechen und es wird not und in
anderen teilen der welt auch hunger
geben nur und das ist an den zahlen aus
brasilien und den usa und immer bedenken
die entwicklung ist ohne schutz
exponentiell gäbe es ansonsten aber und
abermillionen tote und wer das in kauf
nimmt der na ja da gibt es inzwischen
der genügend wörter für ich kann nur
sagen denkmal selbst nachrecherchiert
mal ordentlich im netz und sammelt immer
mehr informationen und quellen erst dann
eine meinung bilden und da hat jeden der
das ordentlich macht noch nie eine
verschwörungstheorie überzeugen können
da gibt es immer immer eine menge
schwächen und hier geht es weiter mit
immer mehr verschwörungstheorien sind
sie eine gute überlebensstrategie das
ist nämlich eine ziemlich spannende
perspektive also unbedingt anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran